Elizabeth at the white house only I was
wearing a hat you might be able to say
that I'm Mary Ann Brownlow welcome to
borders were very pleased to have as our
guest this evening Kevin Phillips whose
new book just out today American dynasty
aristocracy fortune and the politics of
deceit in the house of Bush we are all
here gathered to celebrate its
publication foreign affairs called Kevin
Phillips one of the handful of American
scholars who can treat the American past
and the American present with authority
in 1968 Kevin Phillips was the chief
political and elections analyst for the
Republican presidential campaign and he
served as special assistant to the US
Attorney General for 13 months beginning
in 1969 after publication that year of
his landmark book the emerging
Republican majority Phillips resigned to
become a newspaper and later broadcast
commentator and subsequently served as
editor and publisher of the American
Political Report from 1971 to 1998 from
1984 to 1996 he was an elections
commentator for CBS News since 1969
Kevin Phillips has published eleven
critically acclaimed books including the
politics of rich and poor and wealth and
democracy his eighth book the cousins
war the cousins war religion politics
and the triumph of Anglo America
published in 1999 was a finalist for
that year's Pulitzer Prize in history
Kevin Phillips is a periodic contributor
to National Public Radio in the Los
Angeles Times and an occasional
contributor to Time magazine and
Harper's please join me in welcoming
Kevin Phillips
[Applause]
thank you what I'm going to talk about
tonight is more or less what you expect
it'll be on some of the negative aspects
of the bush dynasty and sort of how they
got there and it was mentioned that it's
a long time ago now that I began a book
called the emerging Republican majority
which came out in 1969 and I say is a
kind of credential for those who at this
point would prefer to think I had no
Republican background it was called the
political Bible of the Nixon era and
thirteen years later in 1982 The Wall
Street Journal described me and again
this is for purposes of evidence as
opposed to puffery of the leading
conservative electoral analysts the man
who invented the Sun Belt named the new
write and prophesy the emerging
Republican majority in 1969 so obviously
this is not exactly where I am right now
and you can fairly say why is this man
writing this book and what is the the
aspect of this book that is different
and that's the first point that I'll
really try to explain then I'll try to
get into three or four of the books
major themes and evidentiary
developments the key word in the title
is dynasty Bush 41 back under George HW
then Bush 43 eight years in between an
absolutely unprecedented pattern of a
president following his father eight
years later with essentially the same
group of advisers and contributors
it's a dynasty by any yardstick and a
dynastic pattern as opposed to two
separate presidencies which is of course
some of the image they would prefer to
convey what it does is it gives you
persisting traits and persisting biases
and the two that all develop in the the
fairly short amount of time we have
tonight will really be the deceit aspect
but also the very
evolution of the Bush family over for
generations and and eight decades with
the intelligence agencies in the
national security apparatus voters
really don't understand this in in a
sense I don't think the media do either
and I'll come back in a minute with some
of the details but before that let me
shift into the related theme that one
family hallmark is two-seat
disinformation and cover-up sort of like
the intelligence agencies and that's not
particularly a coincidence you're all
familiar with the the new book genre
that's emerged on a George W Bush is a
liar
I haven't read in all of these books
I've read bits of them and certainly
they have a considerable amount of
evidence I suppose but as someone who
really got started in politics on a
serious level during the presidencies of
London Johnson and Richard Nixon and
then most recently watched Bill Clinton
you can hardly say that lying is new to
the White House essentially you're
looking at a lot of American presidents
who have been what you could call famous
fibbers I think the interesting
distinction and what makes what's going
on now so distinctive is that the
previous people that you can hold up for
their lack of candor and for their
disinformation and lack of truth-telling
I suppose the previous presidents were
not people who had generations earlier
of their family sort of doing the same
thing what you had whether it was Bill
Clinton or Nixon or Johnson was a sort
of first generation a self-made fibber
so to speak in the case of the Bush's
what you really have very I think
significant and important reasons is
that this goes back quite a ways and how
part of it has been linked to their
antecedents in cloak-and-dagger
circumstances in the intelligence
agencies and the national security
community and I'll fill in some of the
detail
there in a minute but it's also been for
various reasons that I'm not entirely
sure of them it's been systematized
under the bushes in a way that also
doesn't get much attention it has to do
with their enormous interest and the
interest of some of those who work for
them in the various writings and
advisories of niccolo machiavelli the
florentine sage so to speak it's
possible that George HW Bush when he was
CIA director in 1976 in early 1977
became acquainted with Machiavelli under
those circumstances I certainly wouldn't
rule it out there probably 300 copies of
The Prince and Langley it's certainly
very plausible but in this particular
case you can make a more direct
connection karl rove george w's
principal political adviser has has
basically been quoted as someone who
reads Machiavellian a pair of people
named Moore and Slater in a book called
Bush's brain which was mostly about Rove
cited him as as subscribing to the
Machiavelli thesis that appearances
count more than reality
now Rove who used to have a close
association with Lee Atwater who was the
political aide to George HW Bush back in
the late 80s and early 90s he quoted
Atwater as saying that he read
Machiavelli once a year to you know keep
up with the flow of wisdom there a
fellow named John do Leo who was one of
the domestic advisors to George W left
several years back saying everything was
totally politicized and he blamed and I
quote the Maybury Machiavelli's so the
notion of all of this is quite
considerable now it's amazing to me that
without uh you know really any doubt as
to the interest levels in in Machiavelli
that there hasn't been a bit more
attention to what monkey
they actually said because you would
think if you just read sections of the
book that you had come across a bush
White House political memo one of the
the most striking examples here is this
is from the prince a prince must take
great care that nothing goes out of his
mouth that is not full of the
above-named five qualities and to hear
him he should seem to be all mercy faith
integrity humanity and religion
Machiavelli is underlying advice however
as is clear because the most successful
princes he names Cesare Borgia and
Alexander the six have been relentless
deceivers I've kind of the Xerox here
that's faded on its margin so however
it's necessary to be able to disguise
this character well and be a great
Feiner and dissembler and men are so
simple and so ready to obey present
necessities that one who deceives will
always find those who allow themselves
to be deceived and then he goes on to
point out essentially that deceivers are
the ones who make it and one analysis of
Machiavelli's writings in the discourses
says that he generalizes that from the
mean to great fortune people rise by
fraud rather than force and I picked up
whatever books I had on Machiavelli and
looked for the different translations of
all of this and it all coming kept
coming back to the same thing that
essentially go ahead and deceive because
that's the way people have gotten ahead
appearances will outweigh anything else
and you know it's all air in the
different translations it's there in the
books that have been written about
Machiavelli I've never seen it written
up to me it explains quite a lot of
what's going on if you credit that it
could actually be any kind of guideline
and the the reaction that people would
have would be to say well that's all
coincidence people talk about
Machiavelli and they probably don't
really read it and to say that
disappears in Machiavelli sort of like
so what the difficulty I have with
of course is that the vehicle of the
bush family's political emergence in the
United States over the last eight
decades has really been in exactly the
portion of a society and government and
private enterprise system where you
would expect them to read Machiavelli in
the national security apparatus the
early stages of the military-industrial
complex and the intelligence community
for generations of bushes have been
influenced by this and even their
personal finances and style of governing
I think have been influenced by it now
the place to start and it's an
interesting coincidence because today
the president went to st. Louis st.
Louis is where an important part of his
family came from but I was on this
morning with several st. Louis radio
stations and they pointed out that he
didn't mention when he came to st. Louis
that any part of his family came from
st. Louis now one of the reasons why he
might not have wanted to mention it I
don't know for sure that this is true
this is just something was said to me by
my radio people but the George H Walker
for whom he is named and his father is
named George H Walker was an incredible
piece of work who came from st. Louis
and was a sort of 20th century a robber
baron in a gray flannel suit who was the
chairman of a president of a major firm
in Wall Street and the whole process of
his rise was just full of things
connected to the emergence of the
military-industrial complex in the
United States during World War one and
then the period between World War one
and World War two and and more
particularly as sort of really hustling
relationship with overseas efforts and
involvement with the intelligence side
and the easiest way is just to give you
a little sketch here because it's
clearly something the family doesn't
want to talk about of there's just never
any mention of these people and what
did but essentially George H Walker was
a very successful st. Louis financiers L
in in buying out and reorganizing
utilities and railroads and he did this
and got himself up to the point where he
was a small force in Missouri politics
but by the time World War One rolled
around he had this enormous coincidence
that people he knew had a very important
role in the the regulation of the war
and in various things that had to do
with international loans and munitions
purchases he was a friend in Missouri of
David Francis who had been the governor
of Missouri and went to st. Petersburg
in 1916 as a Wilson's ambassador to
Russia
Robert Brookings whose name lives on in
the Brookings Institution was an
educator and and businessman in st.
Louis and he came East and became part
of the war industries board and was one
of the three members of the Allied
purchasing Commission which bought all
the material for for Britain and France
after the u.s. won in the war and still
another friend from the railroad
business and in Missouri out of the the
Averell Harriman camp was a fellow named
Judge Robert Lovett who became one of
the other three members of the Allied
purchasing Commission and the the
great-grandfather of the president
developed something of a specialty and
in wartime finance and and I'm sure made
fair amount of money out of it and after
the war was over Averell Harriman asked
him to head up his new investment firm
which was set up to deal in considerable
measure with overseas investments now at
this point in time
George H Walker was also getting
involved with something called the
American International Corporation which
was something put together by the wall
street crowd in 1915 to invest in war
industries and move some money overseas
to attractive political situations now
the interesting thing about the American
International
corporation was it did a lot of sort of
priests CIA CIA type of work and they
even bought in 1917 an investment firm
in New York called am sinking company
that was had been connected to the
German operations in the United States
before the war broke out well to make a
long story short
George H Walker did get very much
involved with investing in Russia and in
Germany and this became a major
sub-theme of what they did and he was
very closely involved in the world of
intelligence American International Corp
while he was a director of it signed up
the the fellow would have been the
number-two in the State Department
intelligence operation during World War
one so you clearly had a major presence
on the part of George Walker in the sort
of intelligence netherworld
now not to dwell too much on Walker
there's actually an appendix in the book
that has a the one thing I couldn't
resist in terms of it Charlie's the one
chart in the book it shows the interlock
between Walker and W a Harriman and
company and American International
Corporation and Remington Arms and the
company that was the the American
company for a German bank and another
company that was involved with a Homburg
America line so they played big-time
games and by the time the 1930s rolled
around there was some question about
some of these games and some of these
companies and there's not a whole lot of
evidence as to what was involved but you
know it's a little suggestive to think
about what some of it might have been
there was a a bank owned by the teason
Steele family in Germany that was moving
money back and forth across the ocean
but there are no records so you don't
know exactly what they did and I'm not
going to pretend that that I know
now George H Walker had a daughter who
married Prescott Bush and they got
married in 1921 at which time Prescott
Bush got his employ
his jobs and what's really the sort of
post-world War one business spinoff from
the war industries now he had a little
bit of help here because his father
Samuel Bush who had been a partner in
the Buckeye Steel in Ohio a Frank
Rockefeller who was John D Rockefellers
youngest brother Sam Bush got to be the
head of the ammunition small arms and
ordnance section of the war industries
board so he was regulating things like
Remington Arms and so when Prescott Bush
got out of Yale he went into the
artillery maybe there's some question
whether he was actually in military
intelligence but I have no reason
there's no proof of that somebody raised
it but when he came back to the United
States he basically got involved with
war related companies that had developed
their industry and and found things they
had to unload after World War one and
his his father and his father-in-law
that was sort of the business they were
in it was really the the beginning of
the military-industrial complex because
anything before the early 20th century
was relative peanuts in terms of the
huge degrees of military spending that
were nothing were necessary once you got
onto the world scene so to speak a
Prescott Bush went into W a Harriman and
Company essentially as a friend of a lot
of the people in it in addition to being
George H Walker who was the president of
W a Harriman and Company in addition to
being his son an awful lot of his pals
from Yale had been in skullenbones now
skullenbones is you know it sounds silly
it sounds like a joke it doesn't amount
to much anymore but back in that period
an awful lot of the people who were in
skullenbones wound up in the War
Department in the State Department in
the intelligence operations in what
would be the CIA one of Prescott Bush's
partners at Brown Brothers Harriman a
Robert a to love it who was a son of
Judge Lovett
was harriman railroad man he wound up
eventually a Secretary of Defense and he
was the the private architect of the
outline for the CIA which was done right
after World War two but it was never
acknowledged that it wasn't publicly
commented on for another 30 or 40 years
so the the whole group that was around
Prescott Bush and Brown Brothers
Harriman had consisted of people who
would be assistant secretaries of war
for aviation and be deputy heads of the
OSS in London you had loved it who'd
write the Charter for the CIA
you had Henry Stimson and skullenbones
it was a Secretary of War I mean this
was the in-crowd I don't want to
exaggerate that there's some great
conspiracy was just a whole lot of
people who knew each other they were all
on the investment business of the law
business and Prescott Bush was sort of
up to his eyeballs in in association
with these people and some of the people
on the left to write about this have
this notion that Prescott Bush was
somebody who was helping to aid Hitler
and so forth now it's true that some of
these German companies had dealings with
Germany in the 1930s but it's pretty
clear when you look at it all and you
see the associations of Bush and what he
did in the future but he must have had a
tie to intelligence and what would be
the CIA crowd later because some money
of his friends did and he was a director
of the Union Banking Corporation which
was the subsidiary of a bank in Holland
which was owned by the teason Bank in
Berlin and this alien property custodian
seized this Bank in 1942 but Bush in his
his friends at Brown Brothers Harriman
had approached the New York State
banking superintendent the year before
and said you know look this is a touchy
situation what should we do and they
were advised to stay in so my reading of
all of this in total contrast to the
reading of these people that want to do
the drumbeat of of how the pushes were
were aiding the Germans was that no
really
what they were doing was that they were
very closely involved with a War
Department in the intelligence groups
and that that was the basis of their
relations during World War two Prescott
Bush was a director of dresser
industries which was working on portions
of the atomic bomb program and he was
also a director of the vanadium
Corporation of America which was also
working on parts of the atomic bomb
program so the notion that he was some
kind of German friend or something to me
is totally crazy but what he was pretty
clearly looking at the family context
and then look on and see what happened a
little later what he clearly was was
somebody who's very very close to the
intelligence community in the War
Department and it makes perfect sense
and that's the way the family has really
emerged in in their relationships and
what they've done now to go quickly to
George HW Bush now he was the director
of the CIA in 1976 in early 1977 but
actually it was obviously very much
involved with them before and I wouldn't
try to use a descriptive noun here but
the closeness was enormous Yale was the
major recording ground among
universities for the CIA
they had one meeting over in Yale and
they all you know sang the whiffenpoof
song in Piccadilly can you imagine I
mean a real a whole crowd of jelly's and
it between skullenbones and some of the
law firms and some of the investment
banks you had a gripping there
well Nathan Hale actually his he was
Yale class of something or other
ah 1769 or 72 or something and his
statue was right outside the CIA it's
also in front of Connecticut Hall at
Yale so I can't overstate all the yell
stuff here I mean bulla bulla is
probably played on half of the stereos
and Langley not anymore though not in
more but it used to be so the big
question about George HW was whether he
was in the OSS or he was sort of lined
up at Yale like so many others but then
there were really three other theories
now I do this not to have anything
conclusive to say on which theory if any
are totally correct but just to put the
exclamation points after these ties to
the intelligence people in the War
Department dresser industries of which
Prescott Bush had been a director since
1930 was very much involved during the
50s and 60s with Allen Dulles in the CIA
dresser was thought to have had some
some roles in the Caribbean with the oil
services industry uh the bush company
that was set up with the good wishes of
dresser but set up with the lid geese
who wound up doing Pennzoil this was
something called a Zapata Japan of
petroleum now as a paddle offshore is
identified in some of the books that are
not you certainly can swear on the Bible
but they tell more or less the same
story that Zapata offshore which was one
of the first offshore oil drilling
companies was doing work in the
Caribbean that was very convenient for
the period leading up to the problems
with Cuba and supposedly Allen Dulles
used Zapata offshore as a front for some
purchases related to the Bay of Pigs now
i underscore you know there isn't proof
here but this is one of the suspicions
however i found was something that was
absolutely fascinating because maybe
it's maybe it's a weakness of the
liberal mind but they don't particularly
have any interest in business records or
financial records or lists of directors
there's something in new york that's now
known as the green book that's the list
of directors in the New York City area
or people who are directors of New York
area corporations while they were
publishing this thing back in the 20s
and 30s and 40s and 50s and what it
turns out is that part of what George H
Walker did in the 1920s he was the
director of about eight or nine
companies in Cuba
and his son who was George HW s uncle
Herbie no uncle Herbie financed most of
the 41st president oil businesses but
uncle Herbie inherited a lot of the the
Cuban connections and by the 1940s he
was a director of West Indies sugar now
West Indies sugar was one of the biggest
operations in Oriente province which is
where the Castro movement organized in
Cuba and the West Indies sugar was
forced to pay tribute and bribes and
everything to the Castro movement and
then it was nationalized in 1959 or
sixty I forget which year and it went
from having a value of about 50 million
down to basic peanuts now I have no idea
the State of Mind of George HW Bush's
uncle as all of this happened but it's
probably safe to assume and he was not
an admirer of Castro or the
nationalization of the Cuban sugar
industry and it's very easy for me to
believe that you know maybe the company
finanza pata offshore and he was also
skullenbones did a little more of all
the cloak-and-dagger stuff than
anybody's ever said now there was an
interesting document turned up almost by
accident and it was published by the
nation which is a liberal magazine so it
didn't get perhaps the attention that it
should have given all this other
background but it was an FBI document
that the FBI on November 29 1963 and
briefed mr. George Bush of the CIA on
the effects of the Kennedy assassination
in Miami which of course was where all
the people involved in the Bay of Pigs
had been all the people involved in the
whole effort to topple Castro so this
came out and the CIA promptly said no
there was another George Bush it was at
George William Bush but then it turned
out he was a gs5 fellow who did the
contours of coastlines or something so
it probably wasn't him so you get to all
of this and if you wonder is
I did how did we get some Machiavelli
how did we get all this clandestine
stuff how did we get to the cover-ups to
the disinformation well I mean what's
the one industry in Washington that's
been doing this since anybody can
remember the answer is the same crowd
basically that they have had these hard
to categorize relationships with now
there's practically none of this you
can't find in in public places it's it's
all there the big thing that missing was
missing in my mind that nobody ever
bothered to research was the New York
City directory of directors because it
just puts all of this stuff right out on
the table now you can say well that's
that's only three generations that's not
the fourth generation well George W Bush
and his siblings Jeb and Neal and Marvin
have had something to do with a number
of the the banks and SNL's and so forth
that had these ties to BCCI which is a
bank of credit and commerce
international which was related to the
CIA and the iran-contra investigation
and so forth and two other
instrumentalities and and they've been
really active in getting investors from
the Middle East that's another story but
I won't pursue that one right here so
it's very difficult for me to imagine a
that you don't have this overwhelming
case about the background of the Bush's
in relation to the national security
structure and the intelligence community
and be that it doesn't relate to the
whole technique of less than candor
hiding things covering things up it's
sort of what they do in that industry
and to me this is you know an important
situation because when you start putting
it to the test and I'll I'll go through
this and I'll stop I mean as an awful
lot more this is just you know looking
at a little bit of the icing here this
isn't even into the cake yet really
let's talk about the bushes in Iraq here
because this is an extraordinary aspect
of what you get if you have a hide and
coverup and dis inform type mentality
now the elder Bush number 41 and in
1980s was if you were to give him title
of what he did as his vice president you
could say he was the clandestine weapon
agreement and vice president because he
got involved in a number of these that
was true of iran-contra it was true of
what they called a RAC gate where they
were aiding Iraq it was true of the
October Surprise where there were deals
with the Iranians in 1980 in terms of
giving them weapons in relation to the
hostage situation so I thought rather
than you know I'm saying this myself
I'll just quote a few examples of people
who said this and you can sort of take
this as a start this is the opening line
that Ted Koppel used on ABC News
Nightline on June 9 1992 it's becoming
increasingly clear the George Bush
operating largely behind the scenes
through the 1980s initiated and
supported much of the financing
intelligence and military help that
built Saddam's Iraq into the aggressive
power that the United States ultimately
had to destroy I mean that's an
interesting set of circumstances oh let
me give you another aspect to this when
Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait people who
were watching this very carefully
tabulated all the different comments
that came out of the State Department in
the two or three weeks before the
invasion and basically what happened
there relentlessly was that the State
Department was saying we had no
obligation to defend Kuwait and
historically the US had taken no
position on border disputes they were
even asked bluntly
if the United States had a treaty
commitment that would require it to
protect Kuwait and two days before the
invasion of Kuwait the State Department
the assistant secretary Kelly said no no
we didn't have any such commitment and
the CIA William Webster the director had
briefed Bush on July 28th that while an
Iraq evasion of Kuwait was imminent the
Iraqis were likely to enact only the
disputed Rumaila
oilfields and two islands offshore that
black barracks Persian Gulf approaches
well that's what apparently they thought
that was all at Saddam Hussein was going
to do so they didn't have a problem with
that apparently so then of course Saddam
Hussein who figured sort of gotcha you
know he wasn't going to settle for all
this so he he won for the gold not the
bronze and this wasn't something a work
to well politically so you had the
President George HW Bush decided that he
really had to come up with a whole lot
of things that were happening that would
justify all of us that would justify
this invasion so they arranged in
October 1994 a fifteen-year-old Kuwaiti
girl named only as Nayyara
to testify before the human rights
caucus of the US House of
Representatives that Iraqi soldiers
invading Kuwait or hundreds of babies
from hospital incubators and killed them
now it turned out after an investigation
that she hadn't been to any hospital and
she was the daughter of Saud nasir al
sabah Kuwait's ambassador the United
Nations and a relative of the ruling
family that didn't stop President Bush
senior from referring to 312 premature
babies at Kuwait City's maternity
hospital who died after Iraqi soldiers
stole their incubators didn't happen you
know maybe a couple maybe one or two by
some fluke that or or by some gross
trespass but yeah nothing like any
significant number um so there you had
it this is called like the critical
background for weapons of mass
destruction that didn't turn out to be
there now let me give you another little
quotation from man who wrote the book on
the arms build-up called spider's web
the secret history of how the White
House illegally armed Iraq Alan Freeman
published he was a correspondent for the
Financial Times of London came out in
1993 he has four hundred pages of the
details on all this
including Lee the transfer of nuclear
know-how and the the biological cultures
that were sold to the Iraqis and this is
this is a quote from him in the preface
even as Bush asked in the glory of
leading Operation Desert Storm he was
presiding over a systematic cover-up in
order to avoid being embarrassed
politically the Bush administration's
attempts to hide the truth about
American policy or a more insidious
threat to the proper functioning of
democratic government than any weapon
Saddam could have employed interesting
comment this was book was published 14
years ago but when George HW Bush was
defeated in 1992 the whole question of
Iraq aid basically blow away as did the
questions of iran-contra as did the
questions of the October Surprise and so
we get his son is in there and we've got
the whole question of how deception is
going to unfold and you know I would
argue that it did I don't want to get
too heavily into this maybe they had a
sincere belief that the weapons of mass
destruction were everything that were
said but here's a technique that was
identified by the Christian Science
Monitor I'll sort of use this to to
phase out here this is their description
of how the public was mixed up so that
more than a more than a majority
believed that Saddam Hussein was
involved in 9/11 and this is a quote
from the Christian Science Monitor
quote in his primetime press conference
last week which focused almost solely on
Iraq
President Bush mentioned September 11th
eight times he referred to Saddam
Hussein many more times than that often
in the same breath with September 11th
Bush never pinned blamed for the attacks
directly on the Iraqi president still
the overall effect was to reinforce an
impression that persists among much of
the American public that the Iraqi
dictator did play a direct role in the
attacks so obviously what you had
working there was an attempt to sort of
move the peanut with a nut that was
under the walnut
and make it look like you had a
different set of causations and then
work up a better scapegoat now I my
reactions all this is it it's kind of
mind-boggling and I can't figure out why
people can't figure this out
because I made my arrangement to write
this book in December of 2002 because I
had the sense that a lot of this would
never be written but I really didn't
know about a lot of it I wasn't
expecting a lot of what I found but you
know it's not hidden away it's not
secret documents it's stuff you can get
on the internet it's stuff you can get
on the New York City directory of
directors it's stuff you can find in a
lot of places I just wonder where the
press is on this sort of stuff where was
it I worked for Richard Nixon the press
couldn't wait to get up in the morning
to nail Richard Nixon for something what
do they do now I don't know what they do
now but anyway let me stop here and I
will be happy to answer you know any any
more questions on this or on anything
else it released first of all Thank You
mr. Phillips
it's always a pleasure to hear you I the
previous occasions have been up in the
Athens of America Cambridge
Massachusetts I would like you to
clarify something for I was very
interested in eager to hear what you
were going to say about the relief
allegations regarding the involvement in
Nazi the rise of the Nazis in Germany
you said you doubted the relationship
between Prescott Bush and that rise
could you be a little more explicit
about the possible links between George
H Walker and that rises my understanding
and I only just picked us up in a
conversation
in the last day or so about sort of
selling bonds or something we talked a
little bit about that and then I think
perhaps most interestingly as someone I
think who could be considered a genuine
a more genuine conservative could you
talk about how you see this
administration this current
administration from the perspective of a
conservative in America today well as a
lot of stuff in one question on the
bushes in the Germans I've got a couple
of appendices in the book I'm a lawyer I
went to the law school of the Athens of
America I'm not going to stand here and
make careful comments without having the
careful words in front of me but what I
would say is that the New York New York
Herald Tribune in July of 1941 ran a big
article and you know a copy for the
article it's available it's produced in
the National Archives you know I would
think that some of our dedicated First
Amendment stalwarts could get themselves
out there and take a look at it and
basically what it said is at this Bank
the Union Banking Corporation had three
million dollars it might be held for
some of the Nazi bigwigs but it also
said that the Union Banking Corporation
directors including Prescott Bush had
approached the New York banking
authorities and what should they do here
my guess is that this bank during the
20s and 30s probably performed some
laundering functions I don't know what
they would be and I can't say I know
what they would be and I don't think
anybody can prove what they would be so
in the legal sense it's kind of an
abstract question now in terms of what
you can speculate about the teason steel
interests that were the ones that
indirectly owned this bank that was the
pharaonic to solve arc which was the big
steel combine in germany could build a
lot of stuff during World War Two but
the notion that you can hook the bushes
with that is a little far-fetched but I
think it is perfectly fair game to raise
questions about what
some of these corporate links in the
1920s and 30s men especially because one
of the connections I made in the
appendix was they had they had this may
be sort of low-grade rogue Bank the
Union Banking Corporation and it had it
interlocked with some directors who were
one was the head of the Remington Arms
Corporation the biggest munition and and
rifle and other merchant
oh is this a coincidence what's the
interlock what did it do absolutely
clear you just go right to the new york
city directory of directors it's right
there
you know it's just a very short ride
from the offices of a number of
newspapers so I'm not going to hold
forth on the law of this but I think it
is a perfectly appropriate thing and if
the media want to take this as a non
ideological approach uh they can
actually make in my opinion they can
make a total fool out of the people on
the Left who have just gone absolutely
bananas with his cracker stuff you see
on the internet about Bush's funding
Hitler and so forth but what they would
prove would be something it would be
embarrassing to a fair number of people
and you wouldn't have to sensationalize
anything that wasn't there very cold
print there was a Senate committee that
issued a report that discussed the Union
Banking Corporation and I only found
this out right in the last stage of the
book but it's a footnote in the appendix
that gets into all of this so I would
suggest it's an easy thing for people to
follow up I don't want to have many
further comments on it but I will be
suitably appalled if some of this isn't
a serious topic of discussion in the
press your view as a conservative of the
current administration
well one of the lines that I would take
if I were going out and making a stump
speech would be that my view of the the
issues and then the philosophy here was
represented by Lincoln when he said
labor is Morton more important than
capital was represented by William
McKinley when he he wouldn't have a
lobbyist in his cabinet he just refused
there was a fella in Wisconsin who'd
been anti labor and had lobbied for the
railroads and he said to mark Hanna I
won't have a lobbyist in my cabinet
Teddy Roosevelt was the first advocate
of a peacetime inheritance tax Dwight
Eisenhower in 1961 gave a farewell
address against the military-industrial
complex and how we had to guard against
it when I wrote the politics of rich and
poor in 1990 the league quote on the
back of the book jacket and he knew it
was an attack on Bush economics was from
Richard Nixon so as far as I'm concerned
the bushes are not not on the territory
that I regard as a historical turf of
the Republican Party yeah yes you
evidently are suggesting that the Bush
presidency is a threat to the Republic
in some way or a dangerous situation
you've been the author of a cousins war
and you studied the British government
and my question is do you think we would
be safer in this country if we had a
parliamentary government where you
needed that where one man cannot make so
many important decisions as he can as he
began in this country compared to in a
parliamentary system such as Germany or
Britain where you have to get the
support of a parliament well of course
they have a modified parliamentary
system along with the president in
Germany when Hitler came up I'm not
certain that a parliamentary system is
by itself the answer it would curb some
of the excesses but of course Tony Blair
was was able to work with a parliament
in the UK to really go along with all
listen it's hard for me to believe that
he would not have been aware of some of
what I've talked about because there's
been such a close relationship between
the US intelligence community and and
people in the Bush family who've been
close to the brush I just can't imagine
that some of the the background wasn't
known here especially on a rack gate
building up Saddam because British were
involved in that ah nobody should think
that he's got this evil Pentagon that
runs around thinking all this stuff up
and that the British are just a bunch of
people who really rather play cricket
that do nasty things I mean for four or
five hundred years they put the N in
nasty from time to time so I don't think
the parliamentary system by itself is
would be a big change if yeah you
mentioned dresser industries for years
it's a dresser a dress for krauser yeah
for years that has true Salisbury Mellon
our way down the figgety they were
thriving industrial calm
maybe employee
parking lot you judge about 2,000 people
there was a way in Division of that
apparently they were pioneers in my
field gravity-feed gasoline terribly
right all right
but in the late 90s sometimes they were
required by something called calibre
apparently they were squeezed dry for
some item that maybe was patented and
then client no longer exists
understand some people offered jobs if
they went to Texas but that was that I
just wondered there must be a
Halliburton dresser thing and the other
thing whether I've thought years ago
there's been a formal investigation
Center to impressive
related to some of these I don't believe
so one thing I should say there is that
you get into all of this stuff and they
have people who do and they get really
excited about it one of the reasons why
things like this never became an issue
is the W a Harriman and W a Harriman and
company was William Averell Harriman
also known as FDR's ambassador to London
and Moscow mutual security administrator
and in 1950-51
a man was extremely close to the
intelligence community in the defense
department the lawyers for a lot of
these German transactions and this is in
you know five or six books it's nothing
secret at all or John Foster Dulles who
became the US senator from New York by
appointment in 1949 the Secretary of
State and Allen Dulles who became deputy
director of the CIA and then director of
the CIA in 1953 so you know what what's
to be said here really oh you had people
who were involved in certain things it's
obvious the intelligence community was
also involved and that they knew about a
lot of this they had a lot of irons in
the fire they were just watching
everything you could watch the the
original octopus so the chances that you
can drum up some great indictment of
Prescott Bush and you can touch WRL
Harriman and John Foster Dulles and
Allen Dulles I'm you forgot it and there
are people a a lot of people in
Washington who still remember the whole
bipartisan establishment of the 50s and
60s and this was it there's nothing
anybody can do about it it's that's
there but you'll never get more
information on it that isn't out now and
that doesn't lead to anything legal
doesn't lead to any any hard legal
evidence and it doesn't lead to any
solid conclusions it won't be covered by
the media in one respect because you
can't really prove anything more about
it in the back
without standing in the teacher Bush
family connection to the Saudi royal
family to the Laden's and also to the
carlão they're all connected yeah you
know here again I could do a long-long
holding forth on this and there's plenty
of it in the book but it's not public
what the Carlyle Group has is a
structure of who owns what all we know
that until very recently and somebody
told me that George HW which has gotten
out of the Carlyle Group a month ago he
was on the Asian Advisory Committee and
he was a major Rainmaker he went and he
lined up investors Washington Post in
2002 quoted people close to the Saudi
defense ministry as saying that people
in Saudi Arabia had been asked to to
invest in the Carlyle Group as a support
for former President Bush but you know
it's Washington Post I'm not going to
say it's true or is not but it was was
said there the Carlyle Group is an
obviously a sweet piece of work what
they basically do is they've taken
defense and security companies and
they've repackaged them and they've sold
them for two or three or four times what
they bought them for some of them they
still operate the one that was the most
interesting that they had was the Vanel
corporation which essentially trains
foreign police forces and internal
security forces so they train the the
private police of the Saudi royal family
the Saudi national guard and that's one
of the reasons why the Vanel Corporation
has been attacked in Saudi Arabia
several of the attacks have been on
genell but it sort of makes me wonder if
the Saudis had that sort of animosity
you know do they have a larger animosity
towards some of the changes in American
politics and it's a very interesting
thing to speculate about but obviously
our ability to get the details on any of
this is virtually negative
negligible I mean you can't which is
that oh I read one book on The Carlyle
Group I'm sort of tiny tired of reading
books about the Carlyle Group because
nobody can really get in there with
details and hearsay is one thing and
details are another and we've heard
mostly hearsay but I do take it very
seriously in the bin laden's were early
investors in the Carlyle Group
they were also indirect investors in our
busto which was the first of the George
W Bush oil partnerships in the late 70s
they invested through a man named James
bath in Texas and the the analysis in
several of the books about BCCI is that
it must have been the Saudi money that
he was investing because he didn't have
any money at the time and this was all
discussed in the two books about BCCI
that are quoted in my book but again I'm
not going to try to quote them from
memory but all of this stuff is fertile
territory in the back there I get the
impression with the neocons of reading
Leo Strauss Machiavelli Lewis was a
direct student perhaps or Caro is a very
big promoter of Strauss so I wondered if
you you know my comment on that
connection and the second question I had
was am I wrong that your concluding
question was rhetorical that is to say
you said where are the press what are
they doing you know very well what
they're doing they're playing the
administration game that's what they're
doing in the or Kerr came out in favor
of the war in Iraq on the eve of the war
so the real question is why are they
doing so I may be wrong but I just had a
feeling that your concluding question
was rhetorical well I don't think you
can fairly say across the board that
they're all playing the administration's
game I think that's an overstatement but
I would say that they're certainly not
of does a lot of desire to race in and
investigate difficult and very
controversial
portions of this whole dispute and it's
mind-boggling to me that portions of the
connections between the two
administrations just go unanalyzed and
I'm not going to try to put myself in
the thought process of the major
newspapers and networks here but I do
have to feel that you know they haven't
been terribly aggressive I wouldn't say
they're playing the administration's
game I would say that I hope I can stand
at some podium six months from now and
cite four or five stories or
investigations that are spun off by some
of the things that have been raised am I
going to make a big bet on that I don't
know oh the Leo Strauss part I've read
some of the articles talking about how
they were students of Leo Strauss and
picked up on on his ideas Volstead er
was another one but I I don't frankly
think that tracing the antecedents to
people who were genuine intellectuals is
too much of a problem they don't put it
it I've been used to a lot of
intellectuals in politics and after many
many years I don't really subscribe to
the great impact of intellectuals per se
its intellectuals when what they do or
they say gets picked up by other people
and it becomes the basis of something
and I don't think you could say that
about Leo Strauss you know I couldn't
give you a whole lot of information
about him he's registered with me only
in the context that he was a neocon guru
not somebody I associate with having any
political impact in his larger ideology
I couldn't even capsule it for you
nicely
you know I haven't read before all I did
was obviously read the preface waiting
for you to speak but to what degree do
you deal with this process of dynastic
cessation as you call it I mean
you know we have these dynasties like
the Kennedys and Roosevelt's and the
taps and I'm sure if you investigated
any one of them you'll find these into
interlocking directorships all kinds of
deception and shady feelings what's
qualitatively different about Bush that
makes it so much worse well the
situation there is with the Kennedys
obviously you'd get a certain number of
interlocking directorates on things like
the merchandise Martin some of the
businesses they had they basically were
never in the national security or
defense or anything relating to the
intelligence community I mean Joe
Kennedy the founding father the big
thing that the first thing was was real
estate and bootlegging now I mean you
could have an interlocking Directorate
with some of the the mob during the
1920s I'd be willing to stipulate on
that I mean John F Kennedy shared a
girlfriend with a mob leader not
obviously another major media headline
ever so I would say that with the
Kennedys you would have gotten to some
of that on the part of Joe but she
basically never had much attention to
business by the next generation they got
into politics now as far as another
dynasty that's taking shape the Clinton
dynasty and Hillary obviously represents
somebody if she can do it she would
follow her husband in the same timeframe
eight years the George W followed his
father and we can turn into an English
equivalent of York and Lancaster the War
of the Roses and but the only possible
interlocking directorates that I think
could have been found would have been in
Arkansas on some of these sweetheart
real estate deals that that one Clinton
girlfriend would never testify about so
I would never stand up for the Kennedys
or the Clintons that's the Republican
inside of me but I think that the bushes
are different in the sense that what
they have been involved in involves oil
defense intelligence the the whole heart
of national security who haven't
I find myself wondering about whether
the connection between the intelligence
community and business interests is
really the problem here when I when I
think this situation out it seems to me
that the dynastic interests of the Bush
administration are resulting that's been
pushed towards privatization and
privatization is what's keeping the
federal government from doing its job in
defending the national security of the
United States it's a repeated pattern we
see dual use technologies that dual use
export regimen is not effective we see a
self policing international nuclear
industry which ends up supporting and
you know fostering a weapons program in
Libya and it wasn't this wasn't all
Russian and Israel Russian interests we
see privatization of training of police
forces of internal security forces in
Iraq
and they've been utterly ineffective so
I'm wondering if the bush push to defend
his dynastic interest isn't making
privatization oh I definitely agree with
that I would say actually in terms of
the interlocking directorates this
phenomenon in terms of the Bush's losses
ISM its importance after the 60s and 70s
because they basically were not in
business I mean certainly George HW
wasn't at that point he was well he was
for a few years in the late 1970s but
not after 1980 and the privatization
thing is enormous Lee important because
the architect of privatization in the
defense department a lot of ways was
Dick Cheney and Halliburton has been one
of the leading companies going in there
as a private military contractor and
they got that sweetheart deal in Iraq
now I would say they were probably were
very qualified to have a contract in
Iraq but I don't see why it had to be
open-ended that does get a little raw
but they're one of the few companies it
would be qualified to mix military and
oil because that's what they've been
doing
yeah sure whoever two questions first do
you think the sounds for me is have
something to do with that it's copra
down but which side the sounds of the
media is that appeasing has something to
do with defectives overtone and the
second one is you think that the US is
behavior towards foreign policy is that
basically military military-industrial
complex
pushing in that direction you think it's
a broader strategic post cold cold war
plan that the US is implementing where
they've got plenty years from now with
their with territory they're going to
try to take over our antics aware that
everyone father well I think the
military-industrial complex so to speak
has private in the process of
privatization gotten further and further
into energy and into geopolitics and
interests in whether it's Southeast Asia
or the gas resources near the Caspian or
what have you it's very hard to draw the
line now between oil and military and I
think that trend is going to continue
and the profits that you can make out of
the military side are enormous compared
to what they used to be because an awful
lot of the military budget now less of
it goes to just huge numbers of soldiers
and sailors unless if it goes to huge
amounts of Steel on airplanes and
battleships and what-have-you more of it
goes to expensive value added stuff
specialized things communications all
sorts of private contractors that run
computer systems so an awful lot more of
the money that's been on defense and
homeland security is another forty
billion dollars a year now it's a huge
pot of money and the potential to make
eight or ten percent for businesses as
opposed to the two to three percent
which was sort of the average return for
a defense contractor back in the 50s
it's just a much more fruitful set of
opportunities now than it used to be so
I do think that that's a motivation but
I also think that people who have
economic motivations almost always have
them as part of a larger complex
it's hard to say which is the chicken
and which is the egg and I don't doubt
that most of the people involved in this
see these enormous dangers to the United
States and they're worried about our oil
supply and they're worried about the
collapse of countries that could
threaten the whole geopolitical setup so
that they would have more in mind than
simply making money out of the military
but I do think it does enter into their
thought process that the military is
turning into a very lucrative business
opportunity okay thank you
[Applause]